good morning well today is uh what i
hope is an exciting day at khan academy
we're going to kind of start a new set
of uh
i guess we could call them
lectures
but what we're going to do is i'm
actually going to work through just a
bunch of sat problems so what this is
kind of me is like s-a-t prep for free
or or princeton review or kaplan for
free and i hope neither of them sue me
for for using their names but anyway
what i want you to do is if you haven't
already i want you to buy this book
right here the official sat study guide
let me make sure it all fits into the
you'll see it in the bookstore and uh i
hope i'm not doing any kind of copyright
infringement i'm not a lawyer so i don't
know all the rules but i'm pretty sure
you know as long as i give them credit
and that you know that all the problems
we're going to be doing are from their
book and i'm just going to work through
them hopefully that shouldn't be um
something that's that's wrong but anyway
and every day i'm going to well not
every day but as as often as possible
i'm just going to go i'm going to work
through
all of the problems in each of the mat
sections so the best thing for you to do
is
you know for the for the same section do
them ahead of time for yourself try to
do as many as you can
score your test and then whichever
problems you don't know you can just
watch on khan academy and hopefully
understand them or re-understand them so
with that said let's get started so i'm
using this book right here official sat
study guide
and i am starting on page 395 this is a
section three i believe of the first
math section and this is uh page 395. so
sometimes i'll write the whole problem
sometimes i won't
i'm going to assume that you have the
textbook so with that said let's begin
so the first problem problem number one
it says
if
2 x
plus three
two x plus three is equal to nine
then
what is
what is four
x
minus 3
what is 4x minus 3 well this is just a a
a very basic algebra problem if you
don't remember how to do this you should
probably review the level 1 and level 2
linear equations lectures that i have in
the the algebra playlist but the way we
do this we can solve for x here so we
can just subtract 3 from both sides 2x
plus 3 minus 3. so you get a 0 here is
equal to 6
and x is equal to 3.
and so if you do 4x minus 3 that's 4
times 3
minus 3
right and that's 12
and that also equals 9.
and there are some you know you could
have kind of done this a little bit
faster but this is the one way that you
you would make sure that you got the
right answer and on this test it's b9
move on number two
number two
number two there are eight sections of
seats in an auditorium so i alright let
me do another caller just to keep things
interesting
eight
sections
there are eight sections of seats in an
auditorium each section contains 150
seats but no more than 250 seats at
least 150
but no more than 200 so each section so
if we say s is seats let me say s is
seats so
seats
are
greater than or equal to 150
and less than or equal to 200 this is
kind of seats per section hope i'm not
confusing you seats per section which of
the following could be the number of
seats in this auditorium so before i
even look at the choices i mean you
could play the choices you just have to
figure out well what's the minimum
what's the minimum number of seats in
this auditorium well the minimum number
is if every section only has 150 seats
right
so the minimum number is eight times 150
eight sections each of them having 150
seats because this is this is the case
in which every section has the smallest
number of seats so
times eight
zero
forty
one times eight is eight plus four is
twelve so this is the minimum number of
seats
in the auditorium and the maximum number
would be if we assume every section had
the maximum number of seats so that
would be 200
times eight
that's easy two times eight so sixteen
hundred
so we know that seats
let's say seats
is going to be greater than or equal to
this and less than or equal to this and
what choice falls under that range let's
see 800 choice a doesn't it's 800 choice
b doesn't
choice c doesn't choice d 1300 does fit
in that range and we know that choice e
doesn't fit into that range so we're
done it's d
seats is a is a possibility
and we turn the page and we have a
graphical problem let's see what we can
do with this
clear image
colors
okay
note figuring out drawn to scale in the
figure above okay let me draw this and i
think i'll have to
explain how it's done
i will use sky blue
this isn't let's see so in the figure so
let me draw that line
under that no let me do it better than
that
edit undo
draw a thicker line than that so you can
see it
so they have a line like that
and then they have another line that
goes up and down like that
and then they had a bunch of points so
let me draw those points let me
draw those points
i we'll draw them in a different color
so we have point
point a
point
b
c
point
d
e
and they call this horizontal line
they're calling this line l
and then they have another point up here
point x
in the figure above x c is perpendicular
to l so this x c is perpendicular line l
so we know that this is a 90 degree
angle right and i think they draw it yes
they draw that
which of the following line segments has
the greatest length oh and in the figure
they also tell you the measurements of
the different lengths so they say from a
to b is three
from b to c is two
c to d is three
d to e
is one
and from c to x
is eight
okay
which of the following line segments
they're not shown has the greatest
length so there's the first choice i'll
write the choices down actually the
choice a
is line segment x a
choice b
is line segment x b
well this is following a pattern choice
c is sign segment x c
choice d
is line segment x d
and then choice e
is line segment x
e
so which has the
which of the following segments has the
greatest
has the greatest length
so if you just eyeballing it you'll know
that you know this
xb is definitely going to be shorter
whoops xb that was supposed to be xb
xb
is definitely going to be shorter than
x a
right why is that because if you used
well one you could just eyeball it i
know it's not drawn to scale but you
definitely know that this length
this base is longer than this base right
here right so we know it's not going to
be xb we know xb is shorter than
definitely xa so we can cross that one
out right
now what we don't know and we can do the
same thing on the other side of of of i
guess you know this perpendicular line
we know that
x d
is shorter
than x e right
same reason because we know this base is
longer and if you use the pythagorean
theorem you would know that this this
hypotenuse is going to be longer than
this one and you can review pythagorean
theorem and get familiar with the
triangles if that doesn't make a lot of
sense but that tells us that it's
definitely not going to be xd
and we also know it's not going to be xc
this is this is the shortest of all of
them right and you could you could
eyeball that so it's either going to be
xe it's either going to be this
it's going to be xe or xa
and the way we figure out which one has
the longer hypotenuse is we say well
they all have the same height
so which one has a longer base
so
this one has a base this triangle right
here if we say this triangle
has a base of four
and this triangle here has a base of
five
so this hypotenuse will be the longest x
a is the answer
i will see you in the next video